while members of superhero teams like
the avengers and the justice league
may save the world in spite of their
flaws when it comes to the members of
the suicide squad
without their weaknesses they wouldn't
even be part of the crew in the first
place
the biggest weakness of weasel played in
the suicide squad by sean gunn
is his insatiable bloodthirst in the
source material the savage little
beastman is part of one of the most
disastrous task force
x missions on record in terms of body
count and weasel is one of the main
reasons almost no one comes home
in 1988's the dune patrol and suicide
squad special number one
weasel is part of a squad lineup sent to
free the superhero hawk
from a fortress in nicaragua rick flack
leads the squad
which along with weasel includes psy
thinker and mr 104
and he's also the only survivor psy and
mr 104
both killed by the armored soviet
soldiers of the rocket red brigade while
weasel and thinker kill each other
when the squad runs into members of doom
patrol who are also there hoping the
free hawk
things quickly get tense mr 104 an old
enemy of doom patrol
attacks the heroes when thinker tries to
stop mr 104
weasel not caring about 104's grudges
but just wanting to spill more blood
rips thinker's throat open killing him
rick flagg takes thinker's helmet from
the villain's corpse and uses its power
but unbeknownst to flag the villain
imprinted the helmet with the final
command to get revenge on thinker's
killer
before flag removes the helmet it
unleashes a powerful blast
killing weasel instantly as to the
biggest weakness of john cena's
peacemaker
well it's kind of in the name be like a
douchey captain america in spite of
being on a team with the likes of harley
quinn
the gun-toting vigilante suffers
arguably the most singular mental
illness of any other member of suicide
squad
traumatized by the suicide of his father
a nazi concentration camp commander
peacemaker has developed the troubling
philosophy that peace
is worth any cost including killing
anyone he deems an enemy of peace
the guy who believes in peace at any
cost
no matter how many people he needs to
kill along the way
his illness goes so far as to make
peacemaker believe the ghost of his
father
and the ghost of the long list of people
he's killed speak to him from
inside his strange metal helmet
peacemakers internal struggles are
enough to make you wonder why
amanda waller or anyone else would ever
be willing to recruit him
he may be good in a fight but his mental
illness is a glaring liability
if any enemy knows what makes peacemaker
tick and that he hears disembodied
voices
he attributes to the dead it won't take
much to manipulate the vigilante
after all if you believe the best road
to peace is to mow down
everyone who disagrees with you imagine
what other kinds of insanity you could
be made to believe
savant is a genius and he knows it while
he doesn't boast any kind of meta-human
abilities
his intellect and hand-to-hand fighting
skills make him a formidable opponent
and he isn't shy about letting you know
how dangerous he can be
savant originally came on the scene
wanting to become the next batman though
he would eventually decide to turn his
efforts towards blackmail
in the comics savant's time with the
suicide squad makes it clear his biggest
vulnerability
is his arrogance for example savannah is
a part of the squad lineup sent after
harley quinn
when she goes rogue after the team
tracks harley to a police station
savant constantly butts heads with
deadshot almost coming to blows
when deadshot urges savant to take
harley seriously as a threat
saying savant she's dangerous savant
answers
i'm dangerous she's just some psycho
looking for a dead boyfriend's face
once savant goes one on one with harley
that arrogance nearly leads to his death
harley tricks havant into charging into
a jail cell
where she's hid in a pressure mod
savannah's forced to stay there
standing on the mine to prevent the
explosive from going off
harley locks him in the cell and
deadshot is forced to deal with harley
on his own
king shark is one of the most physically
powerful members of the suicide squad he
can breathe underwater and swim as well
as any fish
he's a powerhouse with superhuman
strength and he has absolutely no
compunction about not only killing
but eating anyone who gets in his way
unfortunately
as you might guess king shark isn't the
greatest thinker of dc's characters and
that can lead to complications for him
as well as the squad way play
nice with your brother
true to his name king shark is usually
thinking with his stomach if he's
thinking at all
in 2011 suicide squad number two for
example
as the team battles a stadium full of
grotesquely mutated humans
deadshot has to urge king shark to keep
moving because the man monster keeps
stopping to eat his victims
in the following issue after deadshot
assures his teammates that king shark
knows to keep a low profile the action
cuts to the aquatic villain tearing
through a farmer's chicken coop and
devouring the poor birds inside
in the volume of suicide squad launched
in 2019
it's partly king shark's lack of
intelligence that leads him to become
one of the earliest victims of the comet
in the third issue of that series king
shark lets his guard down in the
presence of his enemy finn
an aquatic character whose brother he
killed and ate two issues earlier
king shark's thoughtlessness in the face
of danger comes back to bite him
literally finn rewards the stupidity
with poetic justice
summoning a nearby school of sharks to
devour him
alicia braga sosoria doesn't appear in
the suicide squad comics or any of dc's
publications so it's tough to nail down
any weaknesses or strengths
however one popular theory suggests
sosoria is a gender-bent version of juan
soria
if that's the case then it doesn't bode
well for the future of this mystery
character
juan soria appears in suicide squad
number 33
and number 34. he's just a regular guy
who dreams of joining the justice league
and when his hand is injured in a
workplace accident he uses the
opportunity to inject nanites into his
body
that give him the ability to open any
lock he tries and fails to join the
justice league and shortly afterward
turns to a life of crime
after the inevitable arrest amanda walla
recruits him into task force
x though his metahuman ability has less
to do with her choice than his crippling
low self-esteem
she sends the squad against a powerful
alien who ends up capturing sorya
and feeding off his energy amusingly
soria's self-critical negative feelings
cause the alien to shrink to the point
where he can kill it by stepping
on it juan soria correctly assumes he's
destined to die
he becomes similar to sam rockwell's
character guy fleegman in the film
galaxy quest
assuming that because he's the new
character with no code name he'll be the
one to die
my character is important enough for a
last name because i'm gonna die
five minutes in guy you have a last name
do i in spite of surviving the battle
against the alien invader he's rewarded
for his service by having his nanite
enhanced hands removed
after which it's revealed that he was
walla's pawn in the plan the whole time
and then walla puts him in the same cell
as killer croc
who it strongly implied uses soria as a
snack
peter capaldi's the thinker is one of
the oldest characters appearing in the
suicide squad
his criminal career dates back to the
golden age of comics and among other
exploits he's one of the founding
members of the injustice society
in the comics the thinker's abilities
stem from the so-called thinking cap he
wears
the cap gives thinker access to powerful
psychic abilities such as telepathy and
telekinesis
without the cap however dinker has no
powers to speak
of even with the cat physically the
thinker isn't particularly formidable
and he appears to be the oldest member
of task force x
this is similar to thinker's situation
in the comics when he joins task force x
in 1988's doom patrol and suicide squad
special
he warns his teammates that he plans to
succeed in his mission and stop
anyone who gets in his way because he's
growing old
and the pardon he's meant to receive for
his service is necessary to live the
rest of his life in peace
but the thinker doesn't survive long
enough to retire when things go sideways
his teammate weasel kills him with a
single swipe of his claw
thinker's biggest weakness then is his
physical vulnerability
his psychic powers make it difficult to
get to him but if somehow you manage to
reach him as weasel does then it doesn't
take much to incapacitate him
as the head of task force x amanda walla
aka the wall
spends most of her time behind the
scenes monitoring the team and making
sure they do what they're supposed to do
when the explosives in one of the
recruits next goes off
there's a pretty good chance it's walla
giving the order to detonate
walla is just as ruthless as the worst
villain she brings into task force x
and can be just as cold-blooded she has
absolutely no moral qualms about feeding
any of her recruits into the meat
grinder including ordering their deaths
the challenge waller tends to face in
every incarnation of the suicide squad
is that while she may be the top dog
when it comes to task force x
she's part of a government bureaucracy
that will only allow her to go so far
outside the box
the original suicide squad run for
example includes story lines in which
rival politicians target walla using
their knowledge of the suicide squad's
actions as leverage
as much as she may want it to be walla's
rule over the suicide squad is not
absolute
she's reminded of this in 2019 suicide
squad number one
when the new volume opens with the
control of task force
x being taken from her by the even more
cold-hearted lock
in the suicide squad fleula borg will
play the former olympic athlete
javelin the crook carries a high-tech
cache of explosive spears
and he's been both a member of and enemy
to the suicide squad a number of times
in the comics
including the 2005 volume of deadshot in
which javelin joins a team of villains
wanting revenge on the expert marksman
javelin's biggest weakness
is fairly obvious with no meta-human
abilities he's highly dependent on his
gimmick weaponry
as an athlete in peak physical condition
his hand-to-hand combat skills are
nothing to sneeze at
but without the weapons that make up his
namesake javelin won't last long
not to mention that even when he does
have his spears they're not always a
help
like just about any comic book super
villain who's been around long enough
javelin has been killed a number of
times only to be resurrected
and more often than not it's been in
part his own spears that kill him
in deadshot number 5 for example the
marksman kills javelin by shooting one
of his explosive spears while it's still
in his hand
years earlier in 1991's war of the gods
number three
the sorceress cersei kills javelin by
impaling him on his own spear
there have been at least three different
comic book versions of bloodsport though
in the suicide squad
idris elba is set to play the original
robert dubra
who comes close to killing superman in
1987 superman number four
after shooting the man of steel with a
sliver of kryptonite
if alba's portrayal of bloodsport is
anything like the source material
his biggest weakness is bound to be his
mental illness including guilt that sits
on his shoulders like a thousand ton
weight bloodsport enters the world of
comics in a bloody rampage across
metropolis
early in the story you get the
impression he's a disgruntled veteran of
the vietnam war he guns down random
civilians all the while proclaiming that
they're wasting the freedoms he
and others fought for eventually we
learned bloodsport didn't fight for
anyone's freedoms
it's superman's pal and daily planet
photojournalist jimmy olsen
who discovers that robert dubra never
served in the military
instead he fled to canada and his
younger brother mickey took his place
mickey lost both of his arms and legs in
the conflict
and it's robert du bros guilt over his
brother's injury that drive him to
madness
superman number four ends with olson
finding mickey and bringing him to the
still rampaging bloodsport who collapses
and tears at the sight of his younger
brother
if elba's bloodsport carries a similarly
guilty conscience
being reminded of his mistakes could do
more damage to him than a kryptonian's
fist
comedian pete davidson plays blackguard
in the suicide squad
and his biggest weakness is well he
doesn't really have any strengths
i'm afraid to say you have died okay
okay
so maybe they're not completely true
blackguard's real name is richard hurts
and he was a common criminal before
being recruited by the powerful
metropolis organization the 1000.
he wears armor capable of generating an
energy mace and energy shield
beyond that he doesn't have a whole lot
to offer he isn't particularly bright
and while his armor would make him a
huge threat to just about anyone in the
real world
in the world of superheroes and villains
it doesn't mean a whole lot
predictably blackguard doesn't survive
his stay with the suicide squad
when the super strong general wade eilig
turns on his teammates in 2008's suicide
squad
number seven blackguard is his first
victim and it doesn't take much of an
effort to kill him
eileen grabs blackguard and rips his
head off before the latter even knows
what's happening
digger harkness aka captain boomerang
first showed up in the 1960s to flash
number 117
kicking off a long career of being a
pain in the scarlet speedster's neck
along with being played by jai courtney
on the big screen
captain boomerang has been a mainstay in
the suicide squad comics for years
while portrayals change as writers and
artists come and go
a regular hallmark of captain boomerang
is also his biggest weakness as far as
task force x is concerned
he's arguably the most consistently
treacherous member of the suicide squad
and it never seems to end well for him
you're free to go
hating amanda walla more than just about
anyone else a tall order in task force x
there isn't much captain boomerang won't
do to escape his service
to pull one over on waller or just to
annoy her he's let teammates die when he
could have easily saved them
he's tricked teammates into killing
themselves and in the case of the young
hack he flat out murdered a colleague
he's also disguised himself as other
super villains to continue making money
while working for the suicide squad
and has pulled elaborate pranks on the
entire team his efforts have resulted in
among other things the thief having what
little privileges he enjoyed revoked by
amanda wallace and in at least one case
had him unceremoniously dropped from a
helicopter and stranded on a deserted
island
rick flag's biggest weakness is that the
suicide squad is the last place he
should be for his sanity
on one hand there are the villains and
vigilantes recruited to the squad
on the other there's the machiavelli and
amanda waller and between them is joel
kinnaman's rick flagg
a soldier who wants nothing more than to
serve his country his place in the
hierarchy
the things he's forced to do as a member
of the suicide squad and his values as a
soldier
all combined to make flag the unluckiest
person in task force x
psychotic antisocial freaks it makes no
sense
flag would rather not be tied to career
criminals for his military service
during his time in both the comics and
the movies flag has worked with killers
thieves and worse he's literally
commanded cannibals as part of his
duties it
forces him to not only overlook past
that many would say shouldn't be
overlooked
but often to turn a blind eye to the
ugly crimes the recruits commit in the
present for flag in the squad
but for better or worse they are his
recruits and as a soldier
flag can't help but feel responsible for
them not to mention that amanda walla
doesn't share his feelings of
responsibility and will readily
sacrifice
any member of the squad without losing a
wink of sleep over it
and when the smoke clears he'll have to
continue taking orders from her
meling un's mongal is the daughter of
mongol an
interstellar warlord who's fought the
likes of superman to a standstill
depending on who you talk to mongal's
greatest weakness is either her lust for
battle or her family
like her father and brother mongal is
blessed with superhuman strength and
resilience
also like the rest of her family mongal
revels in battle
and that could prove her undoing in the
suicide squad if um's version of the
character is anywhere near as powerful
as the one from the source material
she'll be more than happy to charge into
any battlefield without thinking twice
and if the squad comes up against tough
enough adversaries they could get her
killed
if it should happen that mongal's family
somehow makes an appearance in the film
that could prove the key to her
destruction her brother mongol the
younger
kills mongal in 2006's green lantern
number eight
seeing a picture of his father together
with daughter and son mongol the younger
proclaims that family is a weakness
unwilling to tolerate it mongol
decapitates his sister with a single
punch before she can respond
nathan philian will be playing a
character named tdk in the suicide squad
though to die hard comic fans tdk is
better known by the hilarious name
arm fall-off boy the character premieres
in 1989's secret origins number 46
when he tries and fails to join the
legion of superheroes
tdk boasts the ability to detach his
arms and legs from his body
and use them as blunt instruments you
may have often heard people in movies
and tv shows threaten to tear someone's
arm off and beat them with it
well tdk is somewhat kinder he tears his
own arm off and beats you with it
tdk's biggest weakness is pretty glaring
his power
while hilarious is pretty ridiculous if
all he's doing is trying to surprise a
friend or get his buddy sick during a
dinner party
sure he's golden but in an actual battle
he's kind of limited
as soon as he tears off one arm well
that's it he can only tear off the one
arm because he doesn't have anything to
tear the second arm off with and nothing
to swing it with regardless
that leaves his legs without which he'll
have difficulty standing
walking running or even crawling so if
he does remove one of his legs he'd
better be aiming for his opponent's
shins
or what's the point daniella melchior is
set to play ratcatcher 2 in the suicide
squad
we don't know much about how she differs
from the oldest flanagan version of the
character beyond her gender though it
seems likely
considering she's actually referred to
as rat catcher 2 in the film sneak
preview trailer
that the flanagan version is meant to
have existed at some point before the
events of the film
if rat catcher 2 is anything like her
predecessor then it's likely her biggest
vulnerability
isn't tough to figure out flanagan is
one of the many villains to make
batman's life difficult in gotham city
and as rat catcher he's learned to train
and command whole armies of rats
in spite of a pretty bizarre gimmick his
hordes of vermin and his intimate
knowledge of gotham sewer system make
flanagan a formidable foe for batman
or any other vigilante trying to spoil
his plans
but as far as we can tell the suicide
squad isn't set in gotham city
which leaves rat catcher 2 possibly
dependent on two things
an army of rats and a knowledge of
gotham sewers that will be of minimum
help to her
obviously she's going to be in the film
for a reason though it's tough to
imagine
exactly how she's going to transport
armies of rats all over the place
david de smolchen will play the polka
dot man in the suicide squad
along with the condiment king and kite
man polka dot man is one of those corny
batman villains who doesn't really fit
in the kind of gritty dark batman
stories the general public is used to
these days
and usually only surfaces as part of a
gag or parody like lego batman but now
the bad guy who looks like a twister
board is graduating to the live
action big leagues with the suicide
squad without knowing how this version
of polka dot man will be portrayed
just judging by the fact that he's named
polka dot man
makes us suspect his biggest weakness
will be the challenge of being taken
seriously by his comrades
polka dot man is pretty low on the
pecking order of gotham city's long list
of bad guys
and he knows it better than anyone else
it's likely he's going to feel like he
has a lot to prove
on the other hand it's easy to imagine
polka dot man's biggest weakness could
also be one of his greatest strengths
think about it if you were attacked by a
villain calling himself polka dot man
how long would it take you to stop
laughing and how much damage could he do
to you while you were busy not taking
him seriously
surprising no one margot robbie will
reprise her role as harley quinn in the
suicide squad
thanks to the events of 2020's birds of
prey the weakness that would have been
assigned to her a few years ago
isn't in the picture anymore
most fans would likely agree that it
wasn't that long ago that harley's
biggest weakness had one name
joker in both the animated series that
first brought harley to life
and in the comics that followed harley
couldn't resist the joker
no matter how many times he hurt her no
matter how many times he betrayed her
harley would always welcome her puddin
back with open arms
but after the events of birds of prey
harley's learned to be independent
and we don't think she'd even be tempted
to take joker back if he returned
no instead harley's biggest
vulnerability is also perhaps her
greatest strength
and arguably the main reason she's of
any use to the suicide squad
harley has no fear in spite of having no
special meta-human abilities to call her
own
harley would wade into a hail of bullets
if she thought it was a fun thing to do
and she'd do it laughing it's part of
what makes her so dangerous
though it could ultimately send her to
that creepy abandoned amusement park in
the sky
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one